yes selling author walter isaacson has
written biographies of people with great
minds like Albert Einstein Benjamin
Franklin and Steve Jobs Isaacson is here
with his new book it's called Leonardo
da Vinci as you know by now it's
published by Simon & Schuster which by
the way is a division of CBS Walter
Isaacson welcome hey Gil boy it is so
great welcome it's so great to see the
history of Leonardo DaVinci that crosses
all genres but let's talk about Leonardo
because you describe him as a man of eye
catching beauty I like that phrase
flowing golden curls muscular build good
physical strength and a genius but a
different kind of genius uses throw up
Vitruvius man a wonderful drawing I
think you have it that was so fun I
think that's a self-portrait of him it
fits his description totally and it is
an icon of connecting art and science
this is a drawing in which he gets every
proportion exactly right he spends 230
measurements to get it right but he also
does something of unnecessary beauty as
he's standing there and they get in the
earth and in the universe figuring how
do we fit in how is this genius
different from other geniuses though you
know some people like Mozart's a great
genius but in a particular field to me
what's interesting is when you can cross
fields he thought of himself as an
engineer a scientist and anatomist
somebody who loved geology his notebooks
are filled with all of his love of math
and science and nature but also art and
so I think real creativity comes when
you can see the cross currents of nature
as opposed to getting all siloed he was
an expert in so many things and yet he
had no formal education I think it was
lucky he was lucky to be born out of
wedlock which man he couldn't go to the
University so he became what he called
you know a self-taught person he became
a disciple of experiment and experience
and this is the beginning of the
scientific method in a way where people
say well let me test the wisdom I've
been given so he born just as a printing
press comes about Gutenberg and he just
reads everything and he's a person in
history he wanted to know the
about everything you could possibly know
most the aristotelian method in some
ways but you write about his to-do list
sometimes my husband makes fun of my
to-do list but what we can learn from
Leonardo I think you say that to-do list
he just wrote about what is this figure
out this why is the sky blue
what is the tongue of a woodpecker look
like every day we get a list from him of
the things he wants to learn and it's
sort of inspiring and the book is based
on more than 7,000 pages of notebooks
yeah what what do we learn what did you
learn in the course well the cool thing
no before well the cool thing about the
notebooks is that after 500 years we can
still flip through them and see day by
day what he was doing
and fortunately paper was slightly
expensive so on any particular page he's
maybe drawn a sketch of the Last Supper
but then he's doing a little math
experiment then doing mountains and then
doing the swirls and curls until you see
how his mind leaps is jam-packed
I love the Mona Lisa story I mean look
what you have on screen man the fetus in
the womb is like a thing yeah it's very
detailed view but when you talk about
the Mona Lisa smile you said that he
used to bring in musicians to make her
smile but what I thought was interesting
is he would go to the morgue and look at
cadavers he'll back to see the formation
of a smile right when you ask you know
what do you find in the notebook we have
page after page of him dissecting the
human face showing every muscle every
nerve whether the nerve comes in the
brain or the spinal cord and then after
a few pages of it the first slight
sketch of Mona Lisa's smile so we see
how the science connects of the art and
it's inspiring part of it's eerie but
you know he just had this passionate
curiosity for curiosity's sake and so
he's doing anatomy dissections but he
realizes that the beauty of the human
body is connected wouldn't that drive
come from it was just innate for him it
is no no I don't think so I mean I think
there's certain innate geniuses Einstein
is one of them where you know whoa he
got some processing power but I think
with Einstein I mean with Leonardo da
Vinci he pushes himself justly more
curious as Nora said you read those
lists of things he wants to learn
and so that's why he's a more accessible
genius and some of the others I've
written about because we can do that too
we can like he would just say why is the
sky blue it would be in his notebook and
he didn't you've compared into Steve
Jobs we've been saying all morning
you're gonna tell us why the two you see
well you know whenever Steve Jobs would
launch a great product I'm gonna see all
of his products all over the table and
in my pocket at the end he would show
the intersection of two streets liberal
arts and technology and he'd say if you
can stand at the intersection of the
humanities and science or arts and
engineering that's what creativity
occurs to me that's what the trivia man
is all about and Leonardo DaVinci is all
about ten years of research it have made
it bigger
well pictures of the other day when
you're watching CBS this one very nicely
done